un rapide bilan de situation de la
pandémie vous savez heureusement que
dans l'immense majorité des cas cette
infection provoquée le par le sascoc de
est bénigne voir asymptomatiques on
s'est représenté par ce petit schéma qui
montre l'encours black ou violette c'est
le virus et qui dont on voit qu'il
disparaît en même temps qu'à une réponse
immunitaire je n'entre pas dans les
détails ça se passe en quelques jours et
en france 21 1 millions de cas à ce jour
ont été diagnostiqués ce qui est
certainement une sous-estimation mais
enfin qui donne un ordre de grandeur
convenable
malheureusement dans un certain nombre
de cas rares mais pas négligeable il ya
des formes sévères en particulier comme
vous le savez chez des personnes âgées
les personnes malades mais pas
exclusivement et donc l'image de gauche
indique que le virus n'est pas contrôlée
que la réponse immunitaire s'emballe je
n'entre pas dans ces considérations de
mécanismes de maladie mais les chiffres
importants sont à droite en france et
700000 hospitalisations depuis le début
depuis donc le début 2020 et 133 1600
décès dans le monde au moins 5 millions
700 mille décès mon sexe est très
largement sous-estimé dans les pays où
les statistiques ne sont pas
convenablement fait le coc vie
d'aujourd'hui la photographie du jour
c'est que le taux d'incidence est de
l'ordre de 2 5% en décroissance comme
vous le savez puisque il est monté
jusqu'à 3,7 à peu près en 25 janvier
qu'aujourd'hui le variant au micro ondes
les bourbiers un mot est quasi exclusif
représente plus de 99% des cas peut
malheureusement même si le la vague
actuelle est en décroissance des
conséquences médicales sont loin d'être
né en core négligeable puisqu'il y as
moyennées sur une semaine disons de
l'ordre de 2700 hospitalisation par jour
en ce moment dont deux tiers pour que
vides un tiers avec covile cette
distinction qui n'est pas toujours
facile à faire enfin je pense qu'il faut
l'intégrer mais même si on ne prenait
que les 2/3 de 2700 ça fait encore 18
ans est considérable presque 300
hospitalisation en soins critiques par
jour donc entre 80 et 90% pour qu vide
et malheureusement de l'ordre de 285 de
ces par jour ce qui est absolument
considérable donc on n'est pas au bout
de la vague et de ses conséquences et
comme vous le savez largement si bien
que moi les conséquences indirectes sur
le fonctionnement de nos structures
hospitalières donc ça c'est juste pour
vous rappeler mais je pense que mes
prédécesseurs ont fait montré les mêmes
images puisque elles pas elles émanent
en partie 2 sur le comment le coc vu
comment au micro on a gagné la bataille
donc je n'insiste pas juste un petit
rappel sur l'évolution des sources de
sart skov deux donc c'est un virus à arn
hon qui mute sans arrêt donc même chez
un individu chacun d'entre nous infecté
est porteur de différentes souches en
fait sans le savoir qu'ils sont des
petites variations donc c'est l'arbre
généalogique du du virus il sa part à
peu près au milieu vous pouvez sont
repérés les variants principaux alpha
qui a était présent en france venant de
grande-bretagne au printemps dernier on
a déjà presque oublié bêta et gamma on
les a pas trop plu en france tout petit
peu bêta afrique du sud gamma brésil et
delta qui a été très fort l'été dernier
et jules encore cet automne et puis en
bas à droite notre micro ondes qui
arrivent comme vous voyez il est
complètement différent des autres il a
progressé ici il est apparu en afrique
du sud avec une succession de mutation
probablement chez elles mêmes personnes
immunodéficientes et puis un petit bras
collatéral ba2 qui est un variant de
mikron qui a qui vient du danemark qui
semble se développer qui n'est pas plus
pathogène mais pour la l'égard duquel
réponses immunes et très légèrement
distingue de micro n'est pas exclu que
ba2 soit rebaptisé d'une lettre grecque
aussi et aujourd'hui ba2 probablement
ralenti un peu la phase de décroissance
qu'on observe aujourd'hui
voilà donc les
au micro n'est pleine mutation ne vous
inquiétez pas n'essayez pas de tout lire
c'est la séquence de la de l'aspai quand
le comme ç'avait spahic c'est la
protéine principal du virus pour qui
permet au virus de s'attacher aux
cellules et puis danser aussi que celle
qu'induit la réponse immunitaire donc
ses comptes l'aspai qu'on s'immunise par
la vaccination donc vous voyez comparé à
la souche initiale le white ap donc
sauvage c'est le one le virus initial
par définition n'a pas de mutation et
dans le micro il y en a plein delta
bekana beaucoup moins donc au micro na
est apparu comme un virus très très
différent des autres ce qui a induit
moins de sensibilité à la réponse
immunitaire que ce soit la réponse
vaccinale où la réponse à l'infection
donc c'est ça qui lui a permis d'être
sélectionné ça induit avec d'autres
mécanismes auxquels je vais pas rentrer
en détail sur une transmissibilité accru
de l'or de plus 80% passer un ordre de
grandeur mais on est en miroir bien que
ce n'est pas inéluctable du tout
heureusement moindre sévérité génie de
l'ordre de -2 81% alors ça se manifeste
en enfant pour les anticorps si vous
regardez le schéma duo ça vous montre la
réponse anticorps contre au micron chez
des sujets vaccinés par le vaccin father
après la primovaccination c7 diapos est
importante elle montre que c'est marqué
par la flèche rouge c'est que le taux
d'anticorps contre micron extrêmement
faible donc ya pas d'anticorps
pratiquement quelqu'un qui a une primo
vaccination en moyenne a très très peu
d'anticorps contre micron donc n'est pas
très bien protégé il est un peu mais pas
très bien par contre la bonne nouvelle
c'est du schéma du 2 du bas qui montrent
qu'après trois doses donc après le
rappel la réponse s'élève elle devient
très significative hélas elle et elle
est protectrice com va vous le montrer
de la diapo sur donc ce pourquoi je dis
que c'est important c'est que ces
résultats-là confirmée par d'autres
indiquent que le rappelle est absolument
primordial dans le contrôle de
l'infection par en micro et donc des
formes graves ce qui évidemment le point
essentiel donc ça c'est la protection
contre l'infection en carré noir ses
comptes delta en cercle gries et omicron
après la deuxième dose c'est la partie
gauche de la diapositive et que vos
profils du temps il reste plus grand
chose parce qu'on est entre 0 et 20% de
protester contre l' inflexion ici c'est
pas les formes graves c'est infections
vous voyez qu après un rappel de dell de
pfizer au bn tss 2b 2c la même chose
c'est pas mal mais quand même on est à
50 % de protection contre l'infection au
delà de 10 semaines avec le vaccin la
troisième partie et mairena tout 73
moderna c'est un petit peu mieux mais
l'information la plus importante elle
est dans la capsule en bas c'est que la
protection contre la protection contre
le risque d'hospitalisation reste
supérieur à 90% et donc ce rappel est
utile donc dans ce conte dans ce
contexte la couverture vaccinale en
france et est pas mauvaise même si elle
n'est pas parfaite puisque plus de 93%
des personnes âgées plus de 12 ans ont
reçu au moins une dose et presque autant
les deux doses de primo vaccination ça
représente 80% de tous les français tous
âges confondus y compris les bébés qu'on
ne vaccinent pas comme vous savez au
passage vous voyez en bas à droite le
rexy nation des enfants qui
malheureusement ne progressent pas assez
vite c'est même un euphémisme en france
actuellement
alors je me rapproche de vos questions
et du pass je me permets de vous montrer
cette image pour moi elle est assez
convaincante mais j'avais besoin pas
forcément besoin d'être convaincus mais
je pense mais la démonstration c'est une
modélisation qui a été fait par des
collègues économistes des effets du pass
sanitaires sur la couverture vaccinale
et qui montre que s'il n'y avait pas eu
de passes sanitaires la course se serait
prolongée selon la ligne rouge et grâce
au pass sanitaire nous avons eu la ligne
bleue en termes de couverture vaccinale
il s'agit la couverture vaccinale de
primo vaccination ici de sur toute la
population et le différentiel est de 13%
donc on peut estimer que 13% des
français se sont vaccinés grâce au pass
sanitaires les faits parce sanitaire 13
% de français ça fait beaucoup de monde
comme pouvez facilement le calcul alors
est-ce que celle vaccinale en quoi cette
vaccination est utile vous avez carte
graphique ici qui indique la source des
données de la drees vous savez le clou
la direction des statistiques
commissaire la santé qui dont émane la
plupart des informations dont on dispose
avec la santé publique france en haut à
gauche c'est les tests positifs en
fonction du statut vaccinal en jaune non
vaccinés en bleu primo vaccination en
rouge vacciner avec rappel vous voyez
que il ya un effet la vaccination il ya
un effet du rappel il n'est pas expects
acculèrent mais en gros on a fait un peu
plus d'un facteur 2 ce qui montre que le
vaccin continue protégées contre
l'infection contrairement à ce qu'on dit
pas d'une façon majeure mais il ya un
effet et cet effet l'échelle
épidémiologique il est tout à fait
significatif est donc très important en
haut à droite c'est presque la même
chose c'est avec infection symptomatique
donc on a un petit quelqu'un un peu de
rhume par exemple comme c'est souvent
qu'avec omikron et en bas à gauche c'est
la protection contre l'entrée en
hospitalisation conventionnelle ou avec
le différentiel entre les vacciner non
vaccinés s'accroît considérablement on
est dans les ca près ça va dépendre de
l'âge que vous allez voir mais en gros
d'un facteur 10 et à droite ces entrées
en soins critiques l'animation on a le
même type de cours mots qui démontre
l'efficacité de la vaccination dans le
contexte actuel est on si on va un tout
petit peu plus loin toujours avec les
données de l'adresse si on prend les
sujets infectés donc on ne tient plus
compte de l'infection quel est le risque
en fonction son statut vaccinal et en
fonction de son âge d'être hospitalisé
donc la base c'est un don qu'il ya
quatre colonnes qui correspondent à
quatre classes d'âge les vingt à trente
neuf de gauche à droite les 40 à 59 les
60 79 et n'est plus de 80 donc vous
voyez que si on prend successivement les
les quatre donnait donc d'abord ce sont
les personnes qui ont une maxime primo
vaccination complète depuis moins de
trois mois donc un effet de protection
qui est diminue avec l'âge si on regarde
à six mois c'est à peu près la même
chose entre trois et six mois excusez
moi et après à plus de six mois c'est un
tout petit peu moins bien mais le point
évidemment important c'est la quatrième
ligne enfin cinquième si on compte du de
toute première qui est la protection lié
au vaccin des personnes qui ont vu leur
appel est excellente même si c'est un
petit peu moins bien en fonction de
l'âge comme attendu mais de façon
confirmé et on est dans le contexte
d'une infection au micro-ondes c'est le
contexte actuel la vaccination protège
contre les formes graves et ça se
traduise les courts du banc d'essai ou
c'est tout à fait net quelles que soient
les la classe d'âge même chez les sujets
plus jeunes voilà alors dans ce conte
est donc tout ceci pourra réitérer
l'importance du rappel aujourd'hui on en
est à 36 6 millions de français qui ont
reçu de rappel c'est 54% des français un
peu plus de 80 % des plus de 65 ans mais
on n'est pas tout à fait au bout de deux
sets se rappelle donc quand même qu'ils
sont les gens aujourd'hui hospitalisé
qui sont les gens qui meurent de covin
aujourd'hui en france c'est en gros
trois groupes les personnes non
vaccinées et parmi celles-ci celles qui
sont très âgés donc 1 à 450 milles
encore malheureusement d environ 10 % de
patients atteints de pathologies
chroniques diverses qui vont d'un
science rénale obésité cancers maladies
psychiatriques etc et les personnes en
situation de précarité qui sont moins
vacciner il ya aussi les personnes qui
ont reçu la primovaccination mais pas le
rappel et qui ont des facteurs de risque
et enfin un groupe qui pour moi qui est
absolument critique je pense qu'il
vienne qui nécessite qu'on s'y intéresse
encore plus qu on le fait aujourd'hui
qui est un groupe d'environ 300 mille
personnes en france qui sont
profondément immunodéprimés et y
répondent mal ou pas à la vaccination
donc ils dépendent de nous pour être
protégé donc ce sont par exemple les
patients en insuffisance rénale
terminale les patients qui ont mis des
transplantations d'organes certains
types de patients traités par des
cancers ou maladies auto immunes je
planterai dans trop de détails mais
c'est mal à l'imaginer ce qu'ils vivent
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont obligés de
se cacher en permanence le risque pour
eux de mourir de kobe des énormes et on
n'arrive pas à les protéger ou très mal
dans la vaccination ils ont ils peuvent
bénéficier de prévention dans les
anticorps monoclonaux mais c'est pas
complètement évident donc cette
catégorie qui est non négligeable dans
les dents les décès évidemment
indépendamment de la vaccination dans ce
cas sont un problème et justifie de mon
sens une attitude proactive sur la
vaccination y convier sur un concept sur
lequel je reviens dans une seconde qui
que la vaccination c'est une protection
individuelle mais aussi un acte de
solidarité à l'égard de ceux qui ne sont
pas protégés directement et je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure le fait même si
c'était un complet la vaccination
protège partiellement contre l'infection
contrairement malheureusement à ce qu'on
entend trop souvent dans les médias
j'ai mis entre parenthèses évidemment ça
n'a rien à voir mais quand même enfants
et femmes enceintes on a une difficulté
là les femmes enceintes ne sont pas
assez vacciner et il ya des femmes
enceintes qui font des complications
graves ou chivu cela peut avoir aussi
des conséquences pour leurs bébés et les
femmes enceintes doivent être vaccinés
n'y a pas de risques liés à la
vaccination j'aide à manches déjà
mentionné vaccination d'en fournir le
pass vaccinale le pass vaccinale nous on
a contribué à sa mise en place dans une
série d'études échanges informels et on
avait dans un avis qui date je ne suis
plus exactement quand quelque part entre
octobre et novembre on avait proposé au
gouvernement d'inclure le pass le rappel
non parce sanitaires à l'époque donc
c'est c'est absolument essentiel compte
tenu des données qui sont aujourd'hui
encore plus clair qu'elle ne l'était à
ce moment là que le rappelle est capital
donc le pass vaccinale sait jamais que
l'adaptation du pass sanitaire dans un
contexte d'un virus au micron acquis un
très haut taux de transmission si bien
que le lan le concept de passes
sanitaire devenait de mon sens
scientifiquement moins valide parce que
même un test pcr négative 24 heures
avant le jour où on a une action en a un
on est dans un contexte ce site
collectif dont qui justifie à le pass ne
ne sut ne peut pas garantir que le
lendemain on ne sera pas infecté donc
l'évolution par le pass vaccinale de mon
point de vue était absolument logique
permettant donc des activités sociales
en sécurité à condition de respecter les
gestes barrières parce que la
vaccination ne protège pas à 100% et à
condition d'avoir une dans sa doudoune
le fait que le parce que leur appel soit
inclus dans le pass sanitaires bien
évidemment c'est une incitation à la
vaccination ces mêmes on peut dire une
obligation partial je pense qu'il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont ça se
rajoute à l'élément précédent et je
pense que cela est justifié parce que
j'ai déjà indiqué d'un mot mais je le
répète à la fois parce que la
vaccination confère une protection
individuelle mais aussi une protection
collective pour les plus fragiles
d'entre nous dans notre société donc les
patients immunodéprimés et les personnes
très âgées en particulier et même si on
les protège pas parfaitement on les
protège partiellement c'est significatif
et donc je me permets d'insister là
dessus et je pense que c'est une
justification très forte du pasok finale
la situation aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils
restent à peu près de 17 millions de
personnes par rapport aux primo vaccinés
qui n'ont pas reçu leur appel 9 pour ne
pas perdre leur passe d'ici 15 février
sauf que parmi 2 e bien évidemment un
certain nombre étaient infectées et que
l'infection vos rappel on l'a c'est une
des choses quand pucon sur lesquels on a
beaucoup insisté auprès du gouvernement
ces dernières semaines et on est heureux
de savoir qui nous ont suivis je vous
rappelle aussi que l'efficacité du
rappel commence sept jours après celui
ci donc ça va très vite donc ça vaut la
peine de recevoir ce vaccin est
évidemment la question qui est votre
question c'est jusqu'à quand maintenir
le pass d'un point de vue scientifique
et médicale de mon point de vue il ya
deux éléments il faut qu'on soit dans
une situation de taux d'incidence réduit
alors le chiffre précis peut discuter
autour de ça on est à 2500 je pense
qu'il réduit ça veut dire largement
moins c'est au moins dix vingt fois moi
je n'ai pas de cette ni fier que ça y
est les éléments de contexte donc je
peux vous donner un chiffre n'aurait pas
de sens et que surtout je pense que
c'est un élément critique pour de mon
point de vue que la surcharge
hospitalière actuelle je vous connaissez
les chiffres et en gros disparu que les
hôpitaux reviennent un état de
fonctionnement habituel et que les
patients n'ont commis depuis cette
retraitée sans délai sans retard et de
façon efficace et en parallèle que la
couverture vaccinale de rappel soit un
niveau très élevé je pense qu'il faut
que ces deux conditions sur une ça peut
aller assez vite
dans d'une part parce que le on l'a vu
l'incidence est en train de diminuer
assez vite découvrant ce courant mars
les choses je pense que vous avez
entendu des épidémiologistes ont vendu
ou préciser ça la situation devrait
assez satisfaisante et puis décalée de
15 jours là les conséquences spital hier
devrait s'améliorer et puis si les gens
se vaccine suivent les consignes je
l'espère avec ce pass vaccinale de co2 à
voir le rappelle on devrait dans une
situation dans dans je ne peux plus je
ne sais pas quand exactement mais nous
sommes la première quinzaine de février
mais je ne sais pas d'ici la fin mars
avril on enseigne j'espère qu'on
arrivera à cette situation mais je pense
qu'il faut être dans cette situation
c'est mon point de vue d'une agence
scientifique je me permet d'aller un peu
au delà mais si vous ne le souhaitez pas
je m'arrête sadia fait un tout petit peu
de prospective ce qui est très dangereux
ménagement je m'aventure dans un terrain
fragile plein d'incertitudes mais il ce
petit chai magnifie vous à vic en
fonction du temps le en gros la
protection au sens large contre là quand
l'artisan les formes graves de la
maladie c'est ça qui compte on a un
effet la primovaccination il s'effrite
la gelée même j'ai accentué
l'effritement sur cette diapos où on a
un boost un rappel ou bien on a une
infection et cette infection est survenu
plus trois mois après la
primovaccination elle vous rappelle et
le niveau de protection s'élève un
niveau plus élevé donc ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle évidemment ensuite on
entre dans les questions d'où les
pointillés les points d'interrogation
qu'est ce qui se passe ensuite est ce
que cette protection va décroître
rapidement est-ce qu'elle va décroître
lendemain la réponse est je n'en sais
rien il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
interviennent c'est quel type de
variants circuleront dans les mois qui
viennent est ce que ce sera un nouveau
variant complètement différent des
actuels ce qui est possible et on ne
connaît pas a priori son niveau de
violence il peut être très sévère ou pas
sévère du tout est ce qu'on peut voir la
résurgence de variants comme delta par
exemple c'est possible ils
réapparaissent parce que l'immunité
contre lui aura tout petit peu diminué
évidemment là l'espoir d'un nouveau
vaccin notamment de vaccins combinés
donc combinant plusieurs spike pour
essayer de couvrir plus large le spectre
des différences ar skorv 2 c dans les
perspectives de rappels de vaccination
disons à l'automne vous savez que les
industriels travaillent à la préparation
de tels vaccins ce qu'on peut se pense
dire sans se tromper a priori c'est
qu'on peut pas éradiquer ce virus est
d'ailleurs le seul l'unique virus je
vous rappelle qu'ils aient jamais été
indiquée à ce jour ces virus de la
variole grâce à la vaccination mais pour
les virus respiratoires c'est vraiment
illusoire entrer dans les détails si
vous le souhaitez un scénario plausible
mais c'est pas sûr que ce soit celui-là
c'est qu'on évolue dans un contexte
d'endémie avec des vagues épidémiques
type grippé et recrudescence saisonnière
quelque chose comme ça vous avez la
partie gauche du diagramme c'est la
réalité c'est les différentes vagues en
france donc le sommet tout là-haut dia
que via une dizaine de jours la
décroissance je pense pas être assez
rapide et la possibilité donc on est des
vagues d'intensité inconnu
chaque année saisonnières un peu comme
la grippe et qui pourrait amener à des
vaccinations annuel quelque chose comme
ça c'est messi pas sûr que les choses se
passent ainsi donc c'est l'hypothèse la
plus plausible france le tout dernier
mot je voudrais dire s'écarte un peu
plus oui pardon si vous aussi dire que
d'où viendra le prochain variance est
juste pour illustrer le point si j'avoue
reprend tout le spectre des virus il
provient il pète un delta like il peut
venir de quelque part vers bêta il peut
venir d'alpha il peut venir de par là
enfin bref bien partout on n'en sait
rien on est incapable de le prédire
absolument pas capable de le prédire il
faut juste surveiller très attentivement
et forcément il sera sélectionné par un
certain degré détachement d'échappement
la réponse immunitaire anticorps et avec
une virulence que l'on ne connaît pas et
juste je me permets de vous rappeler que
la france n'est pas isolée dans le monde
évidemment vous le savez aussi bien que
moi et que mais que ce nous en dépendons
complètement aujourd'hui il ya eu un peu
plus de 10 milliards de doses de vaccins
administrés
si on compte qu'il faut deux doses plus
un rappel idéalement il faudrait que 24
milliards de doses étaient administrés
donc on est à 40 % d'objectifs l'échelle
mondiale les quand on regarde la
répartition des doses d injection vous
le savez c'est extraordinairement
hétérogènes ou plus les la couleur est
sombre pour chaque pays plus les pays
ont été vaccinées il apparaît
immédiatement que l'afrique est née très
très peu vaccinés mais aussi par exemple
que l'inde n'est que partiellement
vacciner et encore et des vaccins qui
sont pas les meilleures le pakistan est
encore moins bien vacciné etc etc etc il
ya là donc la possibilité de foyers
c'est pas la possibilité la réalité de
foyers résiduels ou plus que résiduelles
majeur de l'épidémie où les nouveaux
variants peuvent apparaître donc la
conclusion c'est cette phrase en anglais
qui a été dit il ya quelques temps par
le quelqu'un du groupe kovacs qui lie l
oms coût qui est appliquée dans la
distribution mondial des vaccins c'est
que nos amis c'est fait il est vrai
c'est que nous ne serons pas en sécurité
tant que l'ensemble de la population
mondiale sera en sécurité et on est
obligés d'intégrer cette dimension
lorsqu'on réfléchit sur ce qui va se
passer en france évidemment voilà je
m'arrête là pour cette présente et merci
beaucoup c'est professeur juste avant de
passer la parole au rapporteur vous dire
mettra tout à fait à titre personnel que
ce que vous venez de nous donner
aujourd'hui de nous dire aujourd'hui me
fait du bien par rapport à ce qu'on a
entendu hier manière soir je passe la
parole à marc meunier
le président merci ce professeur
président du conseil d'orientation
merci c'est cette force au tour de piste
c'est à chaque fois bien petit jus ne
aussi comme vient de le dire alain milon
en train du doute et donc une valeur
scientifique qui nous va bien voilà moi
je devrais revenir à l'objet de notre
commission et donc
vous poser une série de questions sur
votre participation en tant que
président du conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale donc votre
participation sur cette décision qui a
été prise de transformer le pass
sanitaire en passe vaccinale d'abord
dans quelle mesure vous avez participé à
la décision est ce que vous l'avez
participer dans quelle mesure et comment
votre conseil a été formellement
sollicité pour analyser la situation
et donc l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire est ce que votre conseil où
certains de ses membres ont été
sollicités à titre informel de comment
et par qui et dans quelles mesures ont
participé ou pas au conseil de défense
sanitaire
vous pouvez nous re préciser votre
participation et à votre connaissance
quand la décision a été prise
le premier ministre l'a annoncé
publiquement le 17 décembre donc ce
changement de stratégie
qu'est ce qui a donc
voilà c'était décision merci merci
madame
alors le la mise en place d'un du pass
implique des considérations qui vont au
delà de la vaccination je parle que
l'aspect scientifique médicale à papa
des aspects politiques bien évidemment
ce qui implique que nous avons été je
vais revenir consultés nous en avons
nous avons participé de la réflexion
autour de ces questions je l'ait déjà
brièvement évoqué tout à l'heure mais
de façon enfin je crois légitime nous
n'avons pas été les seuls parmi les
conseil informel à
réfléchir sur cette question je fais
allusion en particulier au conseil
scientifique s qui me paraît tout à fait
légitime compte tenu de la question
posée dès ses implications
en pratique j'ai déjà mentionné tout à
l'heure nous avions émis un avis urgent
et j'avais noté la date je vais oublier
tout à l'heure le 29 octobre dernier un
avis donc tout à fait entre guillemets
officielle de notre conseil qui au
passage que vous le savez est accessible
il ya un site c'est assez facile d'accès
à nos amis qui sont trop nombreux
maintenant aujourd'hui on en est à 90 à
peu près parfois ils sont tout petits
mais parfois un peu plus conséquent dans
laquelle nous nous recommandions
d'inclure de leurs appels pour toutes
les raisons que j'ai évoquées tout à
l'heure dans le pass sanitaires donc il
ya un élément qui se rapproche du ski
soit sans suite concernant la mise en
place du pass vaccinale nous n'avons pas
été saisis officiellement mais moi j'ai
eu et plusieurs de mes collègues une
série de contacts informels à vrai dire
ça rejoint le mode mode de mode de
fonctionnement j'ai toutes les semaines
nous on est en contact étroit avec d'une
part les personnes de la task force du
ministère de la santé il ya quelqu'un
qui travaille avec moi qui siègent dans
les toutes les semaines au volant de la
task force pour faire un lien complet je
suis en interaction extrêmement
fréquentes avec plusieurs membres du
cabinet long directeur du cabinet le
ministre chaque fois que nécessaire et
en l'occurrence avec le premier ministre
pour dans le cas la préparation du pass
vaccinale de ce qui m'avait sollicité
pour participer aux réunions en ont
peut-être d'ailleurs certains d'entre
vous étaient présents ou de présentation
je pardon parce que j'ai oublié le terme
il ya interne adéquat du conte ces
réunions de concertation je pense pas
que ce soit le bon terme et qui a eu
lieu par dont un chef un expert de ces
questions plus politiques
décembre de présentation du
rationnel du de la mise en place du pass
vaccinale qui était fait aller avec
l'assemblée nationale est avec vous
j'avais participé à cette réunion avec
le premier ministre donc on a vraiment
eu beaucoup de discussions dans ce
contexte
et sur cette partie là donc encore une
fois c'est plus sous forme de contacts
informels et vous posez la question du
conseil de défense du jeu et nous ne
partirons participons pas au conseil de
défense mais d'une certaine façon nous
les préparons c'est à dire que très
souvent en fonction des questions qui
vont émerger nous sommes saisis en amont
et et nous nous nos avis ou note y
contribuer et puis lorsqu'il ya des
discussions plus importantes du sur des
sujets plus importants d'il y à des
réunions assez souvent préparatoire qui
sont notamment dans l'est en a eu avec
le président la république beaucoup au
premier semestre 2021 et ces derniers
mois + avec le premier ministre et son
cabinet je construis sont les éléments
de réponse que je peux vous donner
deux scènes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
professeur merci pour votre présentation
vous avez répondu un certain nombre de
nos interrogations
je voulais vous interrogez vous dans
votre présentation vous nous avez dit
que le pass sanitaire avait eu un effet
sur le nombre de
de vacciner que vous estimez être est ce
pour cent vous nous avez dit aussi
l'importance du rappel et en particulier
que l'efficacité sur une période de
trois mois était de 90% contre les
formes graves que se passe-t-il au bout
de ces trois mois est ce que
l'efficacité
je suis décroît est-ce qu'on va vers une
quatrième injection pour les les publics
les plus fragiles ou âgées
autre question qu'on entend du sol ou
dans les auditions je sais pas quand
mais peu importe
dans le courant du mois de janvier donc
de cette année il y aurait eu 16 % des
français contaminés par le variant au
micro bon je vais peut-être me
contredire mais peu importe en tout cas
c'est que c'est une information qu'on
nous a données
est ce que ça ne remet pas en cause la
pertinence
de la vaccination et du pass vaccin pas
de la vaccination pardon du pass
vaccinale
est selon vous quels seraient les
critères pour pouvoir lever le pass
alors vous vous y avait en partie
répondu avec la précieuse pital hier et
puis une dernière question
que pensez vous de la communication du
gouvernement qui me semble un peu
brouillonne qui était un petit peu
compliqué je trouve de la part d'olivier
ferrand sur une dose égale une infection
puis une injection enfin c'était un
petit peu complexe alors nous on a je
pense qu'on a tous à peu près compris
mais pour le grand public
m paraît très compliqué merci monsieur
le professeur
alors la quatrième dose c'est une
question qui nous occupe beaucoup ces
temps ci on a émis il ya une quinzaine
de jours si vous avez sur notre site à
une première note sur cette clé dans la
vie parce que c'est une on a été
interrogé par le ministère de la santé
sur cette question et la dgs
spécifiquement pour l'instant on a
répondu c'était à 15 jours non il n'y a
pas d'arguments il ya quinze jours mais
c'est encore vrai aujourd'hui pour
entreprendre une deuxième rappel ou une
quatrième dose sauf à l'exception des
patients immunodéprimés ou en fait c'est
déjà recommandé au préalable parce que
pour les quelques uns qui arrive à
répondre quand même à la vaccination il
ya intérêt à répéter des premiers
l'excitation tous les 3 mois quelque
chose comme ça alors pourquoi on a pensé
jusque là que la réponse était non parce
que même si israël de façon un peu isolé
a pris cette décision mais pas fondées
sur des critères scientifiques solides
s'il n'y a pas de données à l'époque
parce que on n'observait pas de
diminution de l'efficacité protection
contre les formes graves y compris chez
les personnes les plus âgées
guillaume rouzier qui est sorti de cette
salle anna sans vous venez de reprendre
avec son équipe a construit des figures
ce peuple si vous les a montrés à partir
des données de l'adresse qui sont très
intéressantes j'aurais pu vous les
projeter aussi mais qui montre le le
risque d'être hospitalisée en fonction
de l'âge et en fonction du statut
vaccinal et dans le contexte micron et
donc on peut savoir semaine après
semaine que les données tombent de
l'adresse chaque semaine 6 est ce qu'on
voit est ce que la pente du taux
d'hospitalisation des personnes
vaccinées disons les plus fragiles et
plus 80 ans monte ou pas pour nous
c'est un paramètre essentiel pour
prendre la décision jusque là il n'y
avait pas d'élévation significative ce
qui veut dire même au delà trois mois
parce qu'effectivement ya pas de
publications scientifiques montrant une
efficacité au delà trois mois mais donc
sur les données françaises qui sont
quand même assez solide de la bresse ain
quatre mois cinq mois ça a l'air de
tenir maintenant il n'est pas exclu que
si je revenais vous voir dans une
semaine je vous dise linverse ça c'est
la difficulté de l'exercice ou là les
connaissances scientifiques évoluent
chaque semaine mais il faut s'adapter
image chaque semaine j'exagère mais
assez souvent et 6 y apparaissait se
signale alors notre recommandation pour
échanger et de dire que au moins pour
les plus de 80 où les plus 70 dépendant
des données il faille aller vers cette
4e 12 avez vous savez sûrement que les
allemands viennent de prendre cette
décision j'aurais d'ailleurs je suis
intéressé de savoir exactement comment
ils ont pris cette décision c'est pas
tout à fait clair pour moi mais j'ai eu
l'occasion d'interagir collègues
allemands demain là dessus j'en saurai
un petit peu plus c'est presque les
seuls n'y a pas encore beaucoup d'autres
pays qui ait bougé parce que tout le
monde a les mêmes données alors on a
dans une information qui n'est pas
inintéressant qui vient d'israël
puisqu'ils ont commencé à administrer la
quatrième dose depuis plusieurs mois
c'est que le mais on a des données
extrêmement préliminaire qui montre que
dans les quinze jours qui suivent la
quatrième dose les personnes qui ont
reçu cette quatrième dose en niveau de
protection contre les formes graves
multiplié par 3,4 donc ça marche un peu
c'est pas spectaculaire mais ça marche
un peu on n'attend pas la quatrième dose
un bénéfice aussi fort que celui du
rappel il ya des tas d'arguments
immunologiques et qui permet de lire la
question c'est est ce qu'on a quand même
un avantage suffisant donc c'est
aujourd'hui pas de quatrième dose même
pour des personnes très âgées mais c'est
vraiment au sens propre aujourd'hui ça
va un jour ou l'autre ça va changer il
est très probable qu'un moment dans le
dans les semaines ou les prochains mois
il y aura une recommandation de 4e de
hausse pour les personnes les plus
fragiles mais ceux dépendant de ces
paramètres
la deuxième question concernant plein de
personnes 16 % peut-être c'est plausible
ce sont affectés par omikron donc est-ce
que ça remet pas en cause la stratégie
vaccinale et y compris le et le pass
mois face aux pompes dans mon esprit
c'est lié pardon
je pense que non parce que pour deux
choses s'il n'y avait pas eu je suis pas
capable ou faire le calcul exact de
façon disons rigoureuse messi avait pas
eu la vaccination et le passe d'un
bureau le pass contribuer à faire que
des gens se vaccine c'est pas 16% vous
aurez eu mais c'est peut-être 30% ou 35%
et surtout c'est qu'est ce qui se cache
entre guillemets ça se cache pas mais
derrière les 16 % c'est le nombre de
paires de nom de formes graves et que
l'on a on a on l'a vu enfin vous le
savez donc il ya eu malheureusement il y
a encore beaucoup de personnes
hospitalisées
faute d'une vaccination complète et si
elle est encore moins de vacciner on a
encore plus donc le bal la problématique
qui est déjà assez lourde sans être
absolument critique de la charge
hospitalière liés aux qu'ovide serait
bien plus importante donc à mon sens ça
justifie pleinement de poursuivre la
stratégie telle qu'elle est développée
actuellement les critères de lever oui
c'est essentiellement enfin encore une
fois je prends les jeux prend vraiment
les choses sur un plan scientifique il
peut y avoir des critères d'ordre
politique que je peux tout à fait
comprendre dans lesquels je rentrerai
pas pour moi les critères sont ce que
j'ai indiqué c'est à dire arriver à ce
que l'hôpital retrouve une vie
presque sont commises dans tous les cas
suffisamment légère pour que cela n'ait
plus d'impact sur le fonctionnement
global de l'hôpital non vous savez par
ailleurs les difficultés et et qu'en
parallèle on est un niveau de couverture
vaccinale de rappel ici possible
primovaccination aussi ma faim de rappel
tels que l'on puisse avoir une certaine
sécurité pour les semaines et les mois
qui viennent sur les risques de voir
repartir une nouvelle vague les derniers
points la communication c'est une
question à laquelle il est difficile de
répondre non non pas sur un plan de dire
du bien ou pas du soutien du ministre de
tel ou tel c'est que c'est objectivement
difficile c'est un peu mêlé là-dedans
d'ailleurs nous demande notre avis à une
de nos missions c'est aussi de
conseiller sur la communication donc
après tout si ça se passe pas bien c'est
aussi un peu notre faute
mais c'est très difficile franchement
c'est horriblement difficile parce que
les choses ne sont pas carré blanc noir
et surtout j'ai déjà dit il ya cinq
minutes
l'évolution extrêmement rapide les
connaissances font qu'on peut être amené
à dire des choses quasiment en
opposition un peu de temps d'intervalle
sur la question une dose l'équivalence
deux vaccins c'est un sujet sur lequel
nous nous sommes beaucoup battus que ça
fait déjà un petit moment qu'on est ce
qu'on souhaitait qu'il en soit ainsi on
a été écouté mais ça a pris un petit peu
de temps
c'est sûr que si on passe d'une
communication qui disait si vous avez eu
si vous êtes infecté il faudra que dans
quatre mois où lens vous vous ayez un
une une vaccination pour être
complètement protégé à un nouvel
nouvelle vision des choses qui est mais
ce nom c'est pas nécessaire parce que
l'infection vous protège aussi bien que
la dose de vaccin s'est passé c'est vrai
que c'est un virage assez fort c'est
absolument évident il ya un mois mais à
un moment il faut le faire parce que les
données sont là pour le faire mais alors
alors qu'est-ce qui est ce que c'est une
difficulté de la vaccine de la
communication qui engendre la complexité
enfin le difficile compréhension ou
est-ce que c'est pas plus ou moins bien
expliqué j'en sais rien mais j'essaye
juste de dire que se faisaient sûr que
c'est un exercice très difficile c'est
l'exemple que vous avez pris est très
bon mais y en a plein d'autres on
pourrait ont passé en revue un certain
nombre d'autres
merci monsieur et madame poumirol prend
la parole
merci président merci monsieur luis
eur33 question la première porte sur un
des premiers schémas que vous avez
montré pour justifier la troisième dose
et
donc de leur appel vous mesurez les
coraux d'anticorps contre au micro
vous êtes plusieurs à nous avoir dit
répété que ce dosage des anticorps
n'avait pas de sens et de valeur
scientifique prouver donc est-ce que ça
n'aille pas là lorsque paraît un peu
paradoxal la deuxième question c'est sur
la couverture vaccinale parce que au
niveau du groupe socialiste on avait
défendu vous savez les seulement du gie
et
là l'obligation vaccinale en particulier
sur ceux sur ce thème de la solidarité
que vous avez évoqué qu'il parle et
c'est important pour éviter la
contamination en particulier des jambes
même des primes et xterra et alain milon
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure on a eu hier
une punition qui nous un peu décoiffé
ont déstabilisé je ne sais quand il faut
dire mais qui nous disait qu'en fait
cette couverture vaccinale
qu'ils ont fait à 85% n'a pas vraiment
cibler de façon complète les personnes à
risque et que dans des pays voisins qui
n'ont pas eu le passé ni terre on a 800
% de vacciner depuis 80 ans et qui peut
le cacher nous puisqu'on est à 85% et
donc quelque part c'est un échec dû à
légère et j'aimerais savoir un petit peu
s'ils voulaient ce qu'on vous en pensez
si c'est vraiment un échec comment on
peut encore faire soit légère parce que
j'aime beaucoup et la dernière petite
question c'est sur la prospective et
vous vous dites effectivement comment la
vente de plusieurs reprises que ça va
être endémique et que donc où les autos
n'aura comme pour la grippe la
vaccination est ce qu'elles sont il en
fera une vaccination de l'ensemble de la
population ou uniquement des gens à
risque comme détenus conviennent
d'évoquer à l'élan est ce que on
réservera ses vaccinations bien sûr 85
des primes écologiques etc etc etc
là je reviens pas surprendre le mondial
on l'a déjà évoqué pour compléter la
question de mes collègues puisque je
voulais poser cette dernière question y
at il possibilité
techniquement ou industriellement de
comptes de combiner les deux on a seule
sphère grippé et où il trône ensemble
votre question pernicieux sur les
anticorps je plaisante mais vous avez
vous avez à la fois raison est pas tout
à fait raison effectivement à juste
titre vous rappeler ce que je dis et
beaucoup d'autres videmment de mes
collègues disent que se doser les anti
cancer strictement rien pour ce à titre
personnel pour savoir s'il faut avoir un
rappel ou pas c'est juste parce que
lorsqu'on ose des anticorps ont dos tous
les anticorps et pas les anticorps les
plus importants qui sont des anticorps
neutralisants et que par ailleurs à côté
des anticorps ya la réponse cellulaire
et qu'on mesure pas et on sait que comme
en terme de points maintenant on sait
que en termes de protection contre les
formes graves ça je sais timité suler
joue un rôle très important donc je
confirme que c'est absolument à rien
pour chaque individu sauf les personnes
immunodéprimées on a besoin de connaître
ce qu'on peu de leur réponse immune de
ce fait de se faire doser les anticorps
maintenant j'ai montré ces données qui à
elle seule ne serait pas suffisante mais
qui sont quand même intéressante cette
fois ci sur un plan collectif
c'est la s'agissait d'anticorps
neutralisants par ailleurs un délai
donné que je vous ai montré c'est que
c'est une indication sait on a on attend
d'un vaccin dans son efficacité qu'ils
permettent de produire beaucoup
d'anticorps neutralisants ce qu'on sait
que ça ça joue sur l'infection - face à
jouer aussi sur la maladie grave mais si
on a un titre élevés d'anticorps
neutralisants ont réduit le risque
d'infection donc avoir cette information
est utile elle n'est pas suffisante mais
elle est utile
deuxièmement obligations et à l'hiver et
c'est à titre personnel je suis
absolument pas contre l'obligation en
2016-17 j'avais demandé à la demande
madame touraine j'avais travaillé sur la
balle à la vaccination obligatoire du
nourrisson et le rapport que nous avions
faits étaient en faveur de cette
vaccination obligatoire qui a été mis en
place par madame busin et qui est plutôt
bien marche pas plutôt qui a bien marché
sans réserve je pense que moi je crois
qu'on peut dire que c'est un succès donc
sur le principe je suis pas contre et
donc c'est vrai qu'il reste quatre
millions trois cent mille français qui
sont pas vaccinés l'adulte sur le plan
des enfants qui est une autre question
et qu'on aimerait bien avoir vacciné et
parmi elles des personnes fragiles 450
mille personnes très âgées
peut-être un million à peu près perd on
sait pas exactement de personnes qui ont
des pathologies qui les expose notamment
des personnes en situation d'obésité
mais aussi des toutes sortes de
pathologies auto-immunes cancéreuses
psychiatrique surtout addiction ses clés
de ces personnes en situation
d'addiction aux opioïdes sont vaccinés
que pour deux tiers d'entre elles donc
c'est beaucoup moins que le reste de la
population française les la cnam ad nous
donne les données d'un très intéressante
sur le dessus et puis il y avait
beaucoup de personnes en situation de
précarité puis lé vrai opposant enfin ce
qui se passe dans les drom et aussi chez
nous un peu ou pas heureusement pas trop
mais un peu donc on aimerait bien voir
ces personnes sélection est ce que
l'obligation ça fonctionnerait c'est un
poil à la difficulté elle est là c'est
sur un plan opérationnel on est je
rappelle pour les adultes on est à plus
de 18 ans 94% de primo vaccination
c'est le cas à un niveau très élevé et
même lorsqu'on fait fonctionner
l'obligation on n'arrive pas à 100%
comme ont donc le nombre de points
pourquoi là c'est ça quand vous dites
c'est ça et est-ce que l'obligation
permettrait par exemple d'aller faire
que en sorte que les personnes âgées
isolées se vaccine j'ai des doutes et
ainsi idem pour les précaires idem pour
les gentils entre guillemets se cache
malheureuse terrible d'ailleurs parce
que ça signifie des je pense des choses
assez lourdes et dur sur notre l'état
notre société sur l' isolement d'une
fraction de la population de dans notre
société donc j'ai pas mal de doutes par
ailleurs montcelleux des considérations
qui sont moins scientifique je le
reconnais mais en tant que citoyen je me
dis que si on demain on annonce
l'obligation vaccinale dans les drom
vous imaginez
donc bien que je sois très favorable à
la vaccination et éventuellement
obligations je n'y suis pas je pense pas
que ça soit malheureusement la solution
aujourd'hui on a on avait émis un avis
qui a été suivi c'était en mai ou en
juin sur l'obligation pour les
professionnels de santé qui a été mise
en place je pense que c'était une bonne
chose
et ça a permis de faire que ce qui était
hésitant ou éventuellement un peu
réfractaires pour l'immense majorité
d'entre eux se sont vaccinés il le
fallait et c'est toujours et le rappelle
maintenant est inclus dans un homme ça
alors c'est vrai que certains pays font
mieux là les verts que nous les payer
latin en italie espagne portugal ont
mieux vacciner les personnes très âgées
que nous c'est indiscutable ils sont
quasiment à 100% on a parfois du mal à
vraiment c'est 100% m'enfin bref la
question c est là c'est facile de
répondre et ce qu'ils ont mieux fait ou
est ce que c'est la société de leur
société qui est différente si on regarde
les méthodes par lesquelles ils ont
cherché à faire là les verts en gros les
mêmes qu'en france ils ont commencé un
peu plus tôt d'après le gouvernement
s'est inspiré ce qui s'est fait en
espagne ils ont commencé plus tôt mais
ils ont pas fait différemment donc j'ai
fait une hypothèse à je suis pas du tout
sûr que ce soit exact mais j'ai envie de
penser entre guillemets envie de penser
enfin que la structure des familles des
pays latins portugal espagne italie fait
que les personnes âgées les nous aînés
sont moins isolé et logis j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec des
espagnols est qui qui pensent la même
chose et qu'ils ont donc il ya moins de
personnes isolées dans les personnes
âgées et que ceci peut peut faire la
différence cela dit c'est pas une raison
de relâcher les efforts d'aller vers il
ya 11 pour ça encore à peu à peu près
des personnages et plus 85 sont pas
vaccinés il ya une étude qui va sortir
dans très peu de temps
qui montre que pour les personnes en
situation de précarité
beaucoup d'entre elles notamment les
gens du voyage ont été assez peu en
contact avec le
le monde de la santé donc il faut nous
on s'apprête à faire une note la loi du
gouvernement sur cette question il faut
faire plus encore sur la les verts c'est
très difficile parce qu'évidemment il
faut beaucoup de monde ça prend un temps
fou pour arriver à convaincre une
personne mais il faut faire plus c'est
vital au sens propre et sûre sur ce plan
je vous suis complètement bon maintenant
il les résultats sont aussi on peut
nuancer et quand même qu'à arriver à
vacciner en un an 89% des personnes
âgées de plus de 80 ans c'est pas si mal
non plus oui mais c'est vrai que ce
serait mieux d'avoir fait sens on est
complètement complètement d'accord
donc le ciblage des personnes à risque
il faut continuer cet effort je suis
complètement d'accord et si on peut
l'intensifier il faut le faire mais
c'est difficile il faut en être
conscient votre quatrième question
c'était le rappelle ça serait ce que
c'est à tout le monde ou est ce que ça
sera réservé aux personnes à risque
comme la grippe ça va dépendre de mon
avis de la virulence si on est avec un
virus entre guillemets pas trop méchant
comme j'allais dire comme la grippe
m'enfin on sous-estiment aussi un peu la
galerie penser que ces dix mille morts
par an parfois donc et en france barbe
lisez comme vous le savez sans doute les
anglo saxons il va qui vacciner enfants
par un vaccin par incitations nasale
contre la grippe ce qu'on fait part en
france il pourrait discuter donc donc ça
dépendra la virulence et je dirais qu au
delà de au delà ça dépend de la
perception sociétal j'irais là c'est
éminemment politique dans notre société
c'est qu'est-ce que nous tolérons et
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qu'on tolère
en charge de gravité de décès
d'hospitalisation d'une infection
respiratoire on se propose pour ceux ne
se pose pas trop la question pour la
grippe ou les autres virus respiratoires
responsable un très grand nombre
d'infections chaque année
je pense c'est une occasion d'élargir la
question tous les virus respiratoires et
qu'est ce que nous voulons au sein de
notre société non à la responsable de la
réponse à ces questions pardon devrait
dépendre la réponse à la question sur
maxime tout le monde vaque si tout le
monde on vaccine contre malgré leurs
vaccins couple et grivko vite d'abord
c'est possible de le faire ensemble
comme vous le savez déjà et dans la
mesure du possible on a essayé de
promouvoir cela à l'automne est aussi
encore faisable aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
ya des sociétés qui préparent des
vaccins mix creed covin ça peut être il
n'est pas inintéressant la difficulté ça
va être c'est quoi le vaccin kovy d'un
j'ai fait allusion tout à l'heure il ya
plein de plein d'hypothèses aujourd'hui
et les industriels fighter modern halles
sont en train de tester surtout preiser
les combinaisons différentes
mais je joins dhr les deux dans tous les
cas temporellement sûrement les joints
dans un même vaccin ce serait bien ce
serait très bien bien sûr
absolument
si monsieur professeur je vais passer la
parole à madame jasmin qui est en
distance
victoire certes il la parole oui merci
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
fisher je vous en prie croûte avec
beaucoup d'attention alors je suis assez
surprise quand même quand je vous
entends parler des anticorps
yavin test qui existent alors vous
mettez en doute d'après la réponse que
vous avez apporté à ma collègue vous
mettez en tout les réactifs qui sont
commercialisés qui seront spécifiques
qui ont dit l'inspecteur ce principe il
faut le pauvre et laboratoires qui
habilité à fait en poule
pour le sénat des examens délivre des
résultats
avec des taux d'anticorps mais
spécifique pour les ivg les anticorps
anti corrida alors est ce que vous
mettez en doute ces résultats là et
pourquoi vous ne dénoncez pas les
laboratoires qui font les réactifs ils
sont commercialisés et qui sont utilisés
parce que quand vous dites constitution
tous les anticorps moi j'ai
personnellement des résultats mais
pendant vous rapprocher du laboratoire
où ton cas des référentiels existants
pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il faut qu'est
ce qui est vrai et quelles sont les
réelles anticorps particulièrement les
ivg qui sont commercialisés la première
chose à deuxième chose c'est que j'ai
entendu monsieur le ministre monsieur
virant sur bfm ça a été hors prix aussi
bas
signaux
évoquer vos recommandations et parmi les
recommandations que vous vous situez
vous aussi clairement et je voulais
qu'ils pensent que j'ai effectivement le
contenu de ce qu'il dit est dit que pour
bénéficier du pass vaccinale on peut
avoir aucune injection aux infections
plus une dose de vaccin il dit également
si vous avez une injection plus
désinfection aucune infection au milieu
où après vous pouvez conserver le
bénéfice de votre phase vaccinale alors
une défection égale une éjection alors
monsieur le monsieur professeurs c'est
fou pour moi et je pense que c'est
encore plus troupeau toutes les
personnes qui écoutent l'immédiat alors
que nous avons besoin de clarifier les
choses et peut-être peut-être évidemment
d'après la démarche qui est la voix des
cités davantage les gens alors
j'aimerais savoir si vous pouvez
qualifier laisser cette information il
nous a manqué
je vous en pression sur le premier point
peut-être j'ai pas été assez clair je ne
remets pas en cause la qualité du dosage
des anticorps les réactifs et c'est
aujourd'hui les tests disponibles sont
très fiables il ya aucune difficulté ce
que je discute c'est l'interprétation
des résultats ce qui est tout à fait
différent et que je répète donc faut
bien distinguer la validité du test qui
ce plan technique ne pose aucun problème
de l'interprétation des résultats
puisque ses résultats pour une personne
je ne parle pas pour la population en
entier où on peut faire ou une partie la
population pour laquelle on peut faire
des études mais pour une personne ce
dosage d'anticorps ne nous aide pas à
déterminer s'il est protégé où il ou
elle est protégée et donc
influence n'a pas d'impact sur la brèche
de du d'exergue de se vacciner notamment
en pour l'instant d'avoir un rappel
j'espère que c'est suffisamment clairs
sur la deuxième question je reconnais
que c'est pas une question facile il a
été fait allusion tout à l'heure donc
peut-être je peux reprendre les éléments
c on a eu en gros l'équation ça c'est
assez simple c'est une infection et vaut
une dose de vaccin mais il ya quand même
des conditions il faut qu'il ya un
espacement suffisant entre l'infection
et le vaccin sinon les deux se cumulent
dans le temps et non ne font qu'un mais
donc quelqu'un qui par exemple a eu une
première dose de vaccin puis disons un
mois ou deux mois après une infection ça
vaut pour sa deuxième dose est il faut
ensuite qu'ils aident rappelle donc
trois mois après si quelqu'un a eu
d'abord une infection puis une
vaccination qu'on va faire deux mois
après il faudra donc ça lui complète sa
primo vaccination et rappellent trois
mois après et troisième hypothèse
troisième scénario primo vaccination
complète des premières doses deuxième
dose est plus de trois mois c'est
important plus de trois mois après la
primovaccination cette personne fait une
infection cette affection vos dose de
rappel est donc passé vaccinale sans
problème si cette infection et s'ils ont
eu moins de trois mois c'est là qu'ils
aient une petite difficulté après la
primovaccination on considère que ce
n'est pas ça n'a pas la même
signification parce qu'il ne sait pas il
n'y a pas eu l'espace de temps suffisant
pour la réponse immune dans sa qualité
puissent se prendre son ampleur donc
voilà c'est ça les règles je reconnais
que c'est pas complètement simple mais
c'est en gros une dose une une affection
vaut une dose de vaccin mais avec
quelques limites temporelles
merci bien madame lassarade à la parole
oui merci
mauvais s'affichèrent je vais pas
revenir sur le fait que le fasse
vaccinale de l'adulte est un peu occulté
finalement l'intérêt de la vaccination
chez l'enfant ou pas je vois que les
sociétés de pédiatrie se réunissant
webinaire
vendredi soir pour évoquer tous ces
sujets et comment améliorer peut-être la
stratégie vaccinale
moi la question que je me pose c'est ray
c'est facile et les vaccins nouvelle
génération ou anciennes générations plus
traditionnelle à base de recombinants ou
vont sortir ou pas et comment on les
intégrera dans le pasok finale s'ils
passent vaccinale existe encore
sur la première question la question des
enfants c'est vraiment un souci en
france aujourd'hui puisque alors que la
vaccination est ouverte à tous les
enfants de 5 à 11 ans depuis le 20
décembre si je me souviens bien donc on
est maintenant
bientôt deux mois plus tard il n'ya que
disons à peu près 5% des enfants qui ont
reçu une primo vaccination alors dans
les pays voisins qui ont aussi ouvert
cette vaccination à l'exception de la
grande bretagne ils sont à des taux de
vaccinations au plus mal 20% et au mieux
à plus de 50% donc il ya en france une
certaine résistance à cette vaccination
et c'est vraiment dommageable car
évidemment le contexte n'est pas le même
que celui des adultes et évidemment des
personnes âgées
néanmoins on sait tout ce qui peut y
avoir des formes graves chez l'enfant il
ya des eaux suite des enfants
hospitalisés alors que dans la classe
d'âge 5 à 11 ans il y en a à peu près
150 actuellement
certains d'entre eux font cette
complication qu'on appelle le pin's qui
est une maladie inflammatoire retardé on
sait que la vaccination s'était montré
chez les adolescents ou là par contre la
vaccination a très bien marché le grâce
au parti ou que vous passez incidemment
le la vaccination prévient le pipe donc
lillois en est de même chez les plus
petits dans le contexte son micro il ya
peut-être un peu moins de cas mais plus
le nombre d'enfants affectés c'est
évident que cette vaccination est utile
pour protéger contre les formes graves
des enfants elle permet aussi même si
c'est pas immédiat de réduire les
fermetures d'écoles et elle contribue à
réduire un peu la distribution du virus
se tente on a parlé tout à l'heure donc
elle est complètement justifiée elle est
d'autant plus justifié qu'on sait des
données américaines qui voit parce que
les américains ont commencé la
vaccination
avons nous des enfants dès novembre
qu'il est sur le
il n'y a pratiquement pas d'effets
indésirables ici c'est de l'ordre de
moins de 1 pour 500 1000 et ils sont pas
graves en fait c'est donc il ya des
réticences malheureusement alors qu'il
devrait pas y en avoir il ya en premier
lieu des réticences du monde médical des
médecins généralistes et des pédiatres
nous essayons et d'autres essaient aussi
de lever ces réticences j'ai participé
déjà pas mal de webinaires ce soir moi
je fais un webinaire avec les toutes les
filières maladies rares ça ça concerne
les enfants fragiles évidemment il ya
aussi les enfants bien portants et qui
seront plus grand nombre mais les
enfants fragiles aussi sont pas vaccinés
mais je pense qu'il faut que nous
poursuivions les efforts pour
bien expliquer aux médecins aux
pédiatres le bien fondé de la
vaccination des enfants aucune raison de
ne pas les y procéder et puis ensuite
l'étape d'après ont en parallèle
évidemment c'est de convaincre les
familles c'est tout à fait légitime et
les familles en droit de se poser des
questions mais il faut il ya les
éléments de réponse et faire en sorte
que cette vaccination démarre enfin on a
on a vraiment un problème et j'espère
qu'on va arriver en sortir ce serait
quand même dommageable de continuer à
avoir des enfants hospitalisés avec des
pin's et ses faces et ccb toi pardon
d'utiliser ce terme n'est cesser
les nouveaux vaccins alors il ya un an
comme vous savez pro le mans il ya un
vaccin nouveau qui a reçu l'approbation
de l'agencé européenne du médicament qui
méthologie plus classique sous unités
protéique et novavax et on attend un
jour ou l'autre le sanofi qui devrait
dans la même catégorie donc le novavax
va être disponible bientôt courant
février d'ici la fin du mois le nouveau
mac on pourra être utilisée est donc la
vaccination par novavax poids compte est
bon entre guillemets dans le kazakh
final on sait que ce vaccin est
raisonnablement sûr on sait qu'il est
efficace même s'il est un peu moins en
termes de protection que ce soit contre
l'infection ou contre les formes graves
que les vaccins et donc l'idée tous les
cas ce que nous la haute autorité de
santé l'a écrit et nous aussi nous
pensons que ce sont des vaccins que l'on
peut proposer soit aux personnes passent
et ultra exceptionnel c'est 100 ou 200
personnes en france quand une
contre-indication médicale à arn mais je
répète un c'est de l'ordre de 100 à deux
personnes personne pour toute la france
et puis plus important pour des
personnes qui vraiment après de longues
discussions approfondies reste rétive à
une vaccination par le vaccin arn il
vaut mieux évidemment recevoir un vaccin
novavax ou peut-être demain sanofi que
pas de la kz1 du tout c'est évident et
donc dans ce sens là il faudra utiliser
[Musique]
à mon avis c'est plus probable que ce
sont des vaccins est reine mais je ne
peux rien n'est exclu parce qu'il
travaille aussi sur des nouveaux
nouveaux vaccins adaptés aux nouveaux
variants mais je pense que on aura plus
de données en tous les cas l'automne
concernant l'élaboration de vaccins
fondée sur les différents variant où les
combinaisons variant avec les vaccins et
renk avec les vaccins protègent on verra
pour l'anglais
[Musique]